I had a beard for a while
then I got a girlfriend who doesn't like
beards and she was really subtle about
it she'd say things like oh you have a
beard huh
some of my friends like guys with beards
I was like oh that's weird some of my
friends like when people say things
directly
this is a true story I got an audition
for that show billions and I told her
about she's like do you have to shave
for your audition
only question she had about the other
shave for it
no it's I don't have to shave for it
it's an audition it's not like they're
going to watch my tape and go oh my God
he's perfect
but this character's clean shaven
there's no easy fix for this
we'll go with Daniel Day-Lewis
foreign